pourquoi je vais vous exposer le projet
de ma commune sur le favril qui est un
projet qui à la fois je précise tout de
suite ce qui est à la fois porté par la
commune évidemment mais aussi comme
j'étais et je suis toujours d'ailleurs
vice président de l'association des
maires ruraux de france en charge des
questions numériques est actuellement
secrétaire général
il y avait une suite logique dans la
démarche numérique et télémédecine pour
autant pour autant c'était bien pour
répondre à un problème de
désertification médicale que le projet
était mené
donc en fait quelques précisions au
départ donc le projet lancé en 2017 et
j'insiste là dessus parce que 2017
c'était il y en avant le col vides et
les conditions dans lesquelles on a beau
mener ces projets n'a rien à voir avec
ce qui s'est déroulé après après le coc
vide mais ça a quand même son importance
donc l'objectif de bien sûr c'était
évidemment de permettre à mes
concitoyens pas que de ma commune ce que
je rappelle que je suis une mère d'une
commune de 360 habitants donc un projet
comme ça pour 300 salles 60 habitants
s'étaient un peu énorme donc c'était un
projet qui était beaucoup plus large
puisque en fait dans une étude préalable
qu'on a fait avec la caisse des dépôts
pour monter le projet on était pas on
sait on est parti sur un bassin de vie
d'à peu près de 5000 habitants autour de
ma commune en sachant qu'on a des
médecins qui sont présents l'idée
c'était pas de remplacer les médecins
mais bien de compléter l'offre
donc l'idée c'était d'offrir évidemment
un accès
un médecin de réduire la proximité
d'avoir évidemment toutes les garanties
d'un véritable outil de consultation
fallait pas non plus faire n'importe
quoi et puis surtout d'anciens des
constats qu'on avait faits sur le projet
l'étude préalable
c'était de réduire les distances pour
aller au service des urgences quand on
trouve pas un médecin puisque ma commune
est située à 35km de l'hôpital le plus
proche
beaucoup en octobre 2017 jeu présenter
un projet au conseil municipal en disant
voilà on va monter une étude et on va
regarder si on peut pas faire de la
télémédecine dans notre commune donc
qu'il ait eu un long débat parce que
c'était assez précurseur et finalement
j'ai pas eu la majorité enfin à
l'unanimité mais la majorité pour le
faire et donc on a lancé
l'expérimentation
alors pour faire court j'ai d'abord se
souhaiter que ce projet soit aussi porté
par la grèce je ne souhaitais pas faire
un projet dans mon coin
donc je voulais que ça soit portée à bas
en préalable une étude fait par la
caisse des dépôts sur l'état de la
présence médicale sur le département à
la fois que la rs ma compagne il a fallu
que je ferraille un peu avec eux pour
qu'ils aillent m'accompagner sur ce
projet pour arriver sur une autre
solution mais c'était pas celle que je
voulais parce que j'avais un objectif
assez précis puisque représentant les
maires ruraux
il me fallait une solution qui soit très
rurale et je vous expliquer pourquoi
donc j'ai un peu imposé le projet à la
grèce
et pendant deux ans j'ai travaillé sans
relâche c'était deux ans de négociations
avec la rs avec un comité départemental
de santé et je tiens ici à remercier
d'ailleurs sophie work as qui était
préfète à l'époque qui m'a beaucoup
beaucoup soutenus dont j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir une presse est extrêmement à mes
côtés enfin être à mes côtés
ça s'est donc finalement le porteur de
projet a fini par aboutir
donc le principal travail qu'on a fait
avec la rs c'était de savoir comment on
pouvait organiser justement cette
téléconsultations médicales puisque moi
j'ai choisi un dispositif qui est une
cabine qui est distribué aujourd'hui
ashkan des et qui ne nécessite pas et ça
c'est important la présence d'un
professionnel de santé parce que l'idée
qu'on avait derrière dans le dans
l'expérimentation puisqu'on a lancé une
expérimentation c'était de monter un
projet qui venait compenser donc une
désertification médicale
quand vous n'avez pas de professionnels
santé un médecin et un pharmacien un
pharmaciens infirmiers etc puisque dès
la cabine à l'époque hkd
c'était la seule qui permettait de faire
une consultation sentir médical puisque
c'est le patient qui lui même dans la
cabine
accompagné par le médecin ou vision qui
fait sa consultation donc ça c'était
c'est important parce que la rs m'avait
proposé d'ailleurs le ski est
aujourd'hui chez mon collègue mais où
l'idée c'était de voir comment après on
pouvait monter un modèle économique et
organisationnelle à peu près on s'était
fixé un objectif de 3 1000 cabines en
france
donc elle été 2019 au bout de beaucoup
de discussions y compris de par mes
fonctions à la nrf avec le mystère la
santé avec nicolas revel à l'époque
président de la cnam parce que le
principal problème à l'époque c'était le
remboursement des téléconsultations
médicales à cause d'une problématique de
géographie puisque je rappelle que si on
a pas de médecins sur le territoire et
qu'on va les prendre un médecin sur un
autre territoire ils faut qu'ils aient
des accords entre les caisses pas c'est
très compliqué en 2019 finalement j'ai
dit bon ça suffit
je lance l'investissement on a acheté et
donc la cabine parce que c'est plus
facile de tout obtenir des financements
et des subventions en faisant un
investissement et donc j'ai acheté la
cabine et pour ça j'ai été soutenu à la
fois par donc l'état avait au titre la
detr à la fois le département via un
fonds de concours de mode
intercommunalités et c'est ma commune
qui a payé le rsa alors il ya
effectivement le dispositif médical mais
aussi le l'investissement du local alors
sur le fonctionnement c'est assez simple
c'est que on prend des rendez vous par
téléphone ou sur le site internet de la
commune en gros 40 3 % des gens font le
font par téléphone et 56 % le font par
par internet
alors j'ai tous ces chiffres pourquoi
parce que chaque patient rempli un
questionnaire médical pendant un
questionnaire de satisfaction suffire
paramédical justement où j'ai rien à
voir avec le médical
mais l'idée était aussi de mesurer
l'appétence des populations à utiliser
la télémédecine de mesurer un certain
nombre de critères qui nous permettait
de dire est ce que la télémédecine c'est
une solution ou pas puisque notre
crainte aussi parfois de certains
collègues c'est de se dire que si on met
de la télémédecine elle les messins
viendront plus
donc il fallait voir comment on pouvait
compléter les deux alors moi ma
conviction aujourd'hui c'est que
vient compléter l'autre donc c'est très
simple la particularité aussi c'est que
c'est la secrétaire de mairie qui
accompagne le patient jusqu'au local ou
de télémédecine qui explique comment va
se dérouler à la consultation et ensuite
elle le laisse tout seul avec le médecin
pendant la consultation alors c'est le
côté un peu descriptif faut savoir que
la rs au départ me disais oui mais vous
rendez compte si au secrétaire de mairie
elle est malade ou elle est absente
comment vous allez faire
donc j'ai formé une adjointe
et je me suis été formés moi-même pour
l'accompagnement l'entretien de la
cabine puisque le protocole sanitaire
entre chaque patient est très stricte et
donc nous avons été formés par
l'entreprise hkd pour justement assurer
un protocole sanitaire et donc la
secrétaire de mairie le fait de façon
régulière et surtout avec plaisir
puisque c'était innovantes
donc le patient on fait ça
téléconsultation il insère sa carte
vitale il fait la conciliation avec le
médecin il reçoit son ordonnance et la
consultation est terminée donc voila un
petit peu comment ça fonctionne alors au
départ la rs m'avait moi je vais dire
promis qu'on pouvait m'aider
financièrement pour le financement la
secrétaire de mairie pour avoir un de
créneaux d'ouverture plus larges
puisqu'aujourd'hui la cabine à l'axé et
n' est ouvert que aux jours d'ouverture
et horaires d'ouverture de la mairie
et l'idée c'était de faire beaucoup plus
large bon bah j'ai jamais une nouvelle
depuis sur cette financière donc la
télécabine est ouverte que les jours
d'ouverture delà de la mairie alors je
vais vous donner quelques chiffres et
puis après je terminerais là parce que
comme on ne fait deux ans qu'on
interroge les patients donc en gros
on a fait à peu près 130
téléconsultation s'est pas beaucoup mais
on est vraiment en zone rurale les pic
de consultation c'est quand un médecin
et absents malades ou en vacances
65 % c'est plutôt des femmes est alors
un des éléments qu'on voulait voir
c'était l'effet générationnel de la
télémédecine est en fait on se rend
compte que 36 % des gens ont plus de 60
ans donc ça veut dire qu'il ya pas de
barrière générationnel globalement
puisque c'est plutôt des personnes on va
dire c'est pas la jeune génération
d'ailleurs la jeune génération
soit ils sont pas malades soit ils
viennent pas pourtant c'est la
population qui n'a le plus d'absences de
médecin référent donc en termes de taux
de satisfaction c'est important de
savoir comment ils ont vécu l'expérience
est ce qu'ils reviennent ils reviennent
pas et c'est bon autant vous dire que
c'est 96% de très satisfaits le reste
est satisfait non content c'est très
satisfaisant
et ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est
que 96 % nous disent qu'ils vont le
recommander à quelqu'un d'autre
donc ça vient il ya un bouche à oreille
en fait pendant la consultation donc 80%
des gens trouvent que l'utilisation est
très clair c'est assez simple 84 % des
patients disent oubliés la distance avec
le docteur au bout de quelques secondes
sert qu'au bout d'un moment on se rend
même plus compte que le médecin n'est
pas là donc ça c'est important aussi par
rapport au vécu
et puis
pourquoi ils viennent et ça aussi c'est
des choses qui sont importantes à mesure
et 72% c'est parce que le médecin est
indisponible
donc c'est bien quelqu un quelque chose
qui peuvent être compensées et 9 %
indique ne pas avoir de médecin référent
donc on est bien sûr là dessus et puis
les motive les motive c'est généralement
50% c'est des événements isolés 25%
c'est la ldn le suivi et puis les 1 5%
celle du renouvellement de médicaments
voila voila un petit peu pour faire une
synthèse de l'expérience et après
peut-être que je vous expliquerai ou
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire évoluer
demain laventure que j'ai vécu c'est pas
à changer c'est pas une course
d'obstacles c'est plutôt un champ de
mines où chaque fois vous poser le pied
par terre la mine vous explose sous le
pied effectivement pourquoi j'ai pris
cet arrêté tout simplement parce que ce
jour-là on ne trouvait pas de médecin
faisait 30 degrés pour faire constater
un décès à domicile et il a fallu que je
menace au bout de six heures de
recherches vaines où tout le monde se
renvoyer la balle à la sous-préfecture
la rs enfin bref
le samu il a fallu que je menace de
prendre le cadavre et de le mettre
devant la porte pour les obliger à faire
venir un smur voilà un petit peu
pourquoi j'en suis arrivé à prendre cet
arrêté
le but c'était de prendre un arrêté
stupide pour montrer la stupidité de la
situation et ça a marché
il faut savoir que lorsque j'ai été élu
en 2015 je savais qu'au couple de
médecins allaient partir à la retraite
en 2017 les novices et 5000 habitants à
60 km de paris
c'est pour vous dire que les déserts
médicaux sont aussi aux portes de paris
et pendant deux ans j'ai cherché en vain
des médecins mais quand je vous dis j'ai
cherché ça a été un parcours du
combattant incroyable entre ceux qui
veulent 50000 euros et qui vous dit je
suis capable de partir demain ceux à qui
vous trouver un logement secteur social
alors qu'ils sont médecins logements
neufs avec un jardin qui vous dit deux
jardins n'est pas assez grand je prends
pas j'ai même eu un médecin puisque nous
la commune a racheté le cabinet médical
est proposée le secrétariat gratuitement
j'ai un médecin qui m'a dit c'est bien
beau mais il faut embaucher ma femme me
payait les fluides et me loger
gratuitement
donc je vais demander si vous voulez que
je nourrisse le chien n'a pas beaucoup
apprécié mais c'est pour vous donner un
petit peu le l'idée c'est qu'aujourd'hui
les médecins sont les marchands de tapis
ils sont libéraux mm beaucoup l'argent
public je suis désolé j'ai pas beaucoup
de langue de bois mais je jeu j'ai un
parcours atypique et donc j'ai un
discours aussi atypique et je les assume
bon du coup lorsqu'on a eu cette
problématique j'ai déposé cet arrêté et
ça a fait le tour de france en deux
heures de temps et il faut savoir que la
news il est déjà connu pour le retour à
l'envoyeur de déchets mais effectivement
ma vraie fierté c'est d'avoir mis en
place ce cabinet de télémédecine et je
vous racontais très vite en moins de dix
minutes la génèse et donc lorsque
l'information a fait le tour de france
le lendemain soir à 19 heures lorsque
j'ai quitté la mairie à monsieur s'est
présentée à moi et m'a dit voilà
monsieur je suis professeur 5 à l'ombre
de strasbourg et je souhaite vous
rencontrer j'ai mis en place une
solution qui peut vous vous intéressez
et je vais dire écoutez monsieur et 19
heures on verra demain m'a dit écoutez
je vais me faire 500 km l'orgie bon ben
je vous recevoir et il m'a expliqué un
petit peu la télémédecine alors c'est
différent lui s'agit d'un chariot
manipulés par des infirmières et donc à
l'issue de l'entretien je lui ai dit
écoutez monsieur c'est très gentil mais
je n'y crois pas voilà donc c'est pour
vous dire un petit peu dans quel état
d'esprit j'étais
néanmoins j'ai continué à chercher des
médecins et on sentait l'inquiétude
monte on sentait aussi monté un petit
peu la colère de la part des administrés
puisque le maire n'est pas n'est pas là
pour trouver des médecins mais c'est
vers lui construire lance quand il y en
a plus c'est un peu le paradoxe et au
final je me suis documenté sur la
télémédecine sur les différentes formes
de télémédecine et pendant près de deux
mois j'ai lu tout ce que j'ai pu là
dessus j'ai regardé tout ce que j'ai pu
c'est un gros travail mais au moins ça
aurait permis d'avoir une idée très
précise et je suis retourné à nancy voir
effectivement le professeur cinq cadres
et le directeur donc de cette société
grégory galiana qui comme moi un
passionné donc on s'est tout de suite
bien compris et j'ai participé à une
expérimentation j'avais six médecins de
soi ce médecin qui étaient là qui
étaient là pour tester la machine et qui
devait faire dd comment dire des
diagnostics sur des personnes avec
maladies complexes et multiples et ils
ont fait 100 % de mon diagnostic et donc
autant opi médical avait besoin de
montrer que son appareil qui équipait
déjà 150 ehpad était mûr pour pouvoir
s'occuper d'une population et autant
j'avais besoin aussi de sauver ma
population du désert médical est donc
très naturellement l'idée s'est imposée
à moi alors si elle s'est imposée à moi
malheureusement s'est pas imposé à tout
le monde
d'abord mes élus et des médecins du
territoire lorsque j'ai fait la première
expérimentation une attitude
parfaitement effect dire qu'ils ont
rejeté en bloc ce que je voulais mettre
en place néanmoins j'ai pas lâcher prise
et là je me suis senti un peu seul
contre le monde mais j'étais persuadé
d'être dans la bonne démarche et c'était
la bonne solution
et donc j'ai continué j'ai eu pour sa
l'appui de quatre infirmières de la
ville dont une était pourtant la pire de
mes opposants
je vous laisse même pas imaginer ce que
ce que j'avais des fois comme
commentaire mais elle est venue me voir
et m'a dit écoute moi ton truc je vais
faire tourner on s'aimera jamais mais je
vais te le faire tourner paradoxe veut
qu'aujourd'hui ce soit ma meilleure amie
ma meilleure confidences vous voyez ça
aussi été une aventure humaine comme
quoi des fois de tout y compris y
compris de la méchanceté mais vous voyez
comme quoi et donc à cette époque
c'était très compliqué mais elles ont
été tout de suite d'un truc qui m'ont
dit nous on va te faire tourner ton truc
qu'on sera loyal et donc et vous verrez
à quel point c'était important ensuite
et on a commencé à mettre en place des
expérimentations devant la population
alors c'était carrément un cabinet
médical qu'on monte sur la scène de la
de la salle des fêtes et ça dure est
parfois près de quatre heures et on
faisait des consultations complète avec
des médecins qui était à 300 km le
problème c'est que bien évidemment
lorsque on arrivait aux questions
réponses c'était catastrophique puisque
oui mais moi j'ai ça moi j'ai ça oui
mais ce qu'on peut faire sans fin
c'était la question à 100 balles à
chaque question et on ressortait de là
on avait le moral dans les chaussettes
et un parallèle de sa comme mon collègue
gg souhaitez quand même le faire en
partenariat avec la rs et alors là ça a
été
comment vous dire j'ai pas les mots la
première fois que j'ai appelé la rs tout
de suite c'était mais monsieur vous n'y
pensez pas il n'est pas question de
faire la télémédecine on en est pas
encore là on n'est pas en plein désert
médical jeudi pardon bien sûr que si
mais monsieur regarder les chiffres
alors je suis allé voir les chiffres et
les chiffres disent qu effectivement
à laigneville on a 10 km l'hôpital de
clermont et 10 km de notre côté un
hôpital de creil et sauf qu'ils prennent
en compte aussi les médecins du milieu
hospitalier
les podologues les infirmiers et je me
rappelle avoir répondu à cette femme
lorsqu elle m'avait rappelé ensuite j'ai
même été surpris de ne pas trouver les
marabouts
donc c'est pour vous dire que les
chiffres donnés par la rs ne concerne
pas la médecine de ville et regarde sa
façon globale mais nous en médecine de
ville c'est le désert total pour 24
mille habitants n'a plus que trois
médecins
c'est ça la réalité et donc j'ai bien
senti que ça allait être compliqué et
donc j'ai laissé tomber et j'ai continué
mes expérimentations et je vous ai fait
passer le book de près ce qu'on a fait
au fil du temps qui vous montre un petit
peu l'évolution de la situation et donc
du coup lorsque le rsa a été alertée
qu'on continue et les les consultations
ont fait en tout cas les
expérimentations fallait les
démonstrations ils sont venus vers moi
et m'ont dit écoutez on s'est mal
compris
on va aller on va travailler main dans
la main donc j'ai été assez naïf pour le
croire
et au final des trois réunions qu'on a
eue avec la rs ça a été catastrophique
en face de moi j'avais le ban et
l'arrière-ban de la rs l'ordre des
médecins le rps l'ordre des infirmiers
l'ordre dé l'ordre des pharmaciens et il
était je suis désolé cul et chemise pour
tout faire pour que échoue ce que les
nouvelles voulait mettre en place et les
prescriptions qui me demandait était
totalement irréaliste puisque il fallait
que d'abord les gens voient le médecin
en présentiel et que la télémédecine
doivent être faites par le même médecin
du territoire ce qui est stupide puisque
quand on en télémédecine c'est qu'on a
plus de médecins sur le territoire
justement c'est la réalité et donc je
les ai mis face à leurs responsabilités
c'était un peu compliqué et au final ils
ont commencé à me menacer de me
poursuivre pour exercice illégal de la
médecine de poursuivre les infirmières
pour exercice illégal de la médecine
alors que ce qu'on propose est allé au
delà des préconisations de la langue
nationale de santé et ils ont même été
jusqu'à menacer des infirmières de leur
retirer leur diplôme
donc ça a tapé très fort puis on
arrivait de la date d'ouverture fin juin
puis ça tapait fort entre temps les
médecins sont partis en retraite au mois
de décembre et les gens qui n'étaient
pas du tout prêt à faire de la télé
médecine était tellement désespérée de
pas avoir de médecin que petit à petit
ça a mûri dans leur esprit tout ce qu'on
avait mis en place et je m'en rappelle
que la veille de l'ouverture
ça a tapé tellement fort paraissent vous
n'imaginez pas le nombre de mails qu'ont
reçues les infirmières de menaces que
j'ai reçues les filles j'ai dit écoutez
si si vous abandonnez là je vous en
voudrais jamais parce que vraiment là ça
tape très très fort ils ont été jusqu'à
déposer leurs appareils de télémédecine
d'autorité dans le cabinet des
infirmières en leur disant vous
travaillez avec nous et si vous
travaillez que monsieur dietrich
on vous vire alors que ce sont les
libérales les infirmières ils ont été
très très loin au final ils ont ouvert
un cabinet de télémédecine concurrents
dans un ehpad avec les prescriptions
qu'il voulait mettre en place et ça a
été un fiasco absolu et total et dans le
même temps nous le 21 juin 2018 on a
ouvert notre cabinet de télémédecine je
vous garantis qu'on n'était pas très
fier parce que vraiment ça mais taper
très très très fort la veille les
infirmières m'ont dit mais christophe
nos contrées confiance on y va si vous
vous rendez compte qu'on risque d'avoir
les suisses ils demain à la porte
et alors on y va on est dans les règles
oui ah bah alors on y va
et donc on a ouvert comme ça et on
pensait faire au mois de juillet une
vingtaine de consultations et des
premiers mois on a fait une centaine de
consultations aujourd'hui le cabinet
télémédecine de laigneville c'est un
fichier de 2000 patients réguliers et là
où je salue la rs c'est que comme je ne
suis pas affiliés l'aérés sais que je ne
suis pas reconnu j'ai dû prendre en
charge des consultations enfin la
commune a dû prendre en charge des
consultations et ça nous a permis
d'offrir une seconde vie une solution
médicale gratuite et ouverte à tous sur
les neuf villes ce qui fait que ça aussi
permis à télémédecine de développer plus
facilement puisque les consultations du
coup tu est gratuite pour les usagers
même si ça coûte à peu près 100
milliards cent mille euros par an pour
la commune mais c'est un choix politique
et je l'assumé puisqu'on a sauvé la
ville du désert médical grâce à ça et le
paradoxe c'est ce que disait mon
collègue c'est que ce sont les personnes
les plus rétives les plus âgés et les
plus malades qui ont été les premiers à
venir tester et qui ont été nos
meilleurs ambassadeurs
aujourd'hui voilà c'est 2000
2000 patients réguliers c'est un cabinet
qui ne fait même plus débat
quand malheureusement n'est une panne
technique c'est là que le drame survient
alors qu'avant c'était le fait d'avoir
un télémédecine et l'effet tunnel fait
qu'effectivement on se focalise sur
l'écran sur l'infirmière qui hélas est
au bout de deux minutes
on oublie que c'est que c'est de la
télémédecine
on a même sauvé des vies avec ça juste
un exemple on a un marathonien qui est
venu faire une visite médicale
alors on a un héros cardiogramme on aa
l'appareil pour faire les échographies
et tout ça donc c'est un outil très
performant et le docteur qui était en
ligne vous souhaitez faire quand même
une échographie parce qu'elle entendait
un petit peu moins d'un côté que de
l'autre le pouls et donc elle a fait une
échographie des carotides et ce
marathonien des carotides qui était
complètement bouché et ça s'est joué à
quelques heures donc voila vous voyez
c'est un exemple parmi d'autres et donc
aujourd'hui l'expérience montre que la
télémédecine et mur qu'elle est capable
de répondre aux besoins des habitants et
qu'elle il répond aussi bien
véritablement aussi bien qu'un médecin
traitant
je remercie beaucoup je vais passer la
parole à mon collègue de moutier et puis
ensuite à son binôme patrice hier chez
nager et puis ceux qui parmi nous qui
sont là en présentiel ou ceux qui sont
en vie j'ai aussi vous avez des
questions n'hésitez pas à indiquer votre
souhait de prendre la parole
pierre philippe merci madame la
présidente
merci messieurs pour le témoignage alors
j'avais déjà eu l'occasion de rencontrer
aussi est riche
merci en tout cas de ne faire pas à la
fois de votre réalisation mais également
du parcours j'ai entendu c'est à dire du
parcours de combattant qui a été
nécessaire pour pouvoir arriver au
résultat que vous avez aujourd'hui alors
même si les choses bougent en matière de
réglementation en matière d'acceptation
la télémédecine auprès des habitants et
au pôle administration les choses
restent dans tous les cas compliqués
mais c'est vrai vous avez aussi un peu
essuyé les plâtres par rapport aux
initiatives lancées en tous les cas
comme l'a dit la présidente c'est parce
que à un moment donné vous avez
voulu retrouver une réponse ingénieuse
sur votre territoire
au regard de toutes les contraintes que
vous êtes comme aussi assortir cette ce
service important pour les populations
alors on dans notre démarche de rapports
avec patricia celle âgée et c'est un peu
la marque de fabrique un peu de la
délégation on s'épie surtout beaucoup
sur les expériences vécues qu'elles
soient heureuses ou malheureuses
d'ailleurs parfois mais on essaie
toujours de mettre en avant
et donc c'est évident que le parcours et
les contraintes et le résultat favorable
que vous avez tenus va alimenter nos
réflexions en sachant qu auront
construit toute sa zone de d'autres
communes de tailles différentes
département région pour peut-être
préciser elle un peu plus loin dans le
débat j'aurais peut-être deux questions
particulières même si je sais j'ai une
partie des réponses parce qu'on avait
l'occasion de rencontrer c'est peut-être
revenir dans un premier temps sur l'es10
montceau quand même financières
notamment je pense à vous parce que je
pense que le coût de fonctionnement de
la télé de la télécabine au regard du
budget de la commune de d'être non
négligeable donc j'aurais voulu qu'on
revienne un petit peu sur grosso modo
connaît ça coûte
l'équipement comme un coûteux et
télécabines mm par exemple et big
allemand le coût de fonctionnement
afférents à ce service on a vu qu à
laigneville il y avait cent mille euros
de prise en charge des consultations
mais il ya aussi d'autres frais donc ce
sera important pour nous de bien le
situer hors garde pour montrer l'effort
que vous avez mis en place au regard de
cet élément là et puis ma deuxième
question et vous l'avez un petit peu
évoquée mais j'aurais quand même revenir
là dessus c'est quand même aujourd'hui
comment s'inscrit le service que vous
avez créés dans le projet de territoire
de santé parce qu'on fait bien qu'au
moment donné alors on a vu les freins au
démarrage
comment les médecins
on perd sur les choses comment les
infirmiers les provenaient de santé mais
à un moment donné place est en place il
ya eu quand même une accélération dans
la mise en place d'aidés d'état et des
territoires de santé et j'aurais voulu
avoir voilà savoir comment c'était
vraiment là ça a souri parce que c'est
par cette initiative est peut-être des
corrections ne pourrions apporter selon
m administratif que on peut certainement
apporter un potentiel de développement
sur le territoire national merci ici à
peut-être on peut faire ses premières
séries de questions chères patricia tu
m'entends oui oui vous me connaît très
bien on tente on a très bien et on te
voit bien patricia mayr bonjour
président bongo en école avec des
messieurs les maires donc mon collègue
expliquer le but de notre rapport moi je
veux bien mais plutôt sur le sujet
téléconsultation et surtout il a
expliqué qu'à un moment donné vous
prenez les consultations à votre charge
donc la caisse d'assurance maladie dont
deux médecins vidéo disent que les
téléconsultations ne sont pas si elle
émane d'une organisation territoriale
l'histoire autrement dit si elles sont
pratiquées par les médecins le deal du
territoire résidence on est vaste en ce
moment même nous avons les collègues qui
est non loin de chez vous nicole durand
tranquille peut justement une question
orale sur ce principe puisque c'est le
département je pense qu'ils ont un dotée
en médecins par habitant
donc on aurait eu au north bay en voisin
monsieur le maire biya nous aurons nous
aimerions savoir ce que vous pensez et
surtout comment est ce que vous voyez
l'avenir le nombre parce que en même
temps c'est un peu contradictoire
puisque
pendant la crise sanitaire ces obstacles
de l'hôtesse ont été tempérés donc le
gouvernement autorise un moment donné
mais n'autorise aucun autre moment donc
il faudrait qu'on travaille
et puis avoir aussi votre retour vous
avez pris en charge donc à hauteur de
cent mille euros les consultations
c'est pas possible pour toutes les
communes donc à peut-être avoir des
précisant qu'au moment où vous avez pu
le faire et m'a donné mes questions et
c'est surtout le savoir le profil des
utilisateurs de ces télés cabine on nous
dit que les jeunes sont intéressés et
surtout ils ont peint des médecins
référents
il dira comment comment est-ce qu'ils
ont accès facilement à ces c'est et
consultations et puis les premières
réalise en vous avez dit on était
peut-être très bonne mais au fil du
temps est ce que l on changé et puis
comment est ce que vous faites campagne
de de l'information pour assurer qu'il
faut logiquement les patients parce que
c'est la pédagogie c'est pas c'est pas
facile
est ce que le personnel que vous
utilisez c'est personnel communal où
c'est indirectement du bénévolat en tout
cas avoir plus de précisions dans non ce
qui est autour de cette télé mixi merci
il je propose que vous vous répondez à
nos deux co rapporteurs
ensuite notre collègue de normand jean
michel où le gade aura une question et
moi aussi quelques points merci beaucoup
je sais pas qui veut répondre jeu
je suis bien demeurer monsieur maire de
le favril alors
toutes ces questions sont très
pertinents c'est par le coup le coup en
tout cas ce qui concerne le favril la
cabine n'est vendu je crois à l'ugap
autour de 80 mille euros donc c'est un
achat et c'est une solution je précise
que en fait l'entreprise laisse gérer
directement les messins entre
les remboursements et un parent brouilla
panne intermédiation ou de deux coups
qui est rapporté par rapport aux 1100
cirque c'est complètement noir en gros
il amène la solution après la relation
au patient mais sien ça se fait entre
donc voilà il ya en gros n'y avait pas
de l'argent sur les médecins
pour le dire ça en terme de
fonctionnement donc c'est un
fonctionnement qui est de gros 1400
euros par an - qui comprend tout ce qui
est matériel ti et la maintenance etc
etc
donc ce qui permet de fonctionner ses
1400 ans qui fait un peu plus de 15000
euros pour la commune du favori
donc donc ça c'est pour le coup
l'organisation par rapport aux cpts donc
dès le départ je disais j'avais voulu
que j'ai voulu que la rs soit impliqué
sur le sujet et les le dépeint j'ai
souhaité rencontrer la cpt est ce qui
était en train de se constituer au nord
de notre département
d'ailleurs s'appelle noël nord-ouest à
feurs et loire et donc j'ai eu des
échanges à l'initiative de l'acteur
on a eu pas mal des changes avec la cpps
pour voir comment vous pouvez intégrer
dans la cpt l usage de la télémédecine
donc j'ai pas eu d'hostilité j'ai eu à
l'époque l'hostilité plutôt du président
de l'ordre à la présidente de l'ordre
des médecins du département mais en tout
cas au niveau la cpds pas de difficulté
particulière parce que en fait la
difficulté c'est qu'il n'y avait pas de
temps de médicales disponibles par
rapport aux médecins en place pour
pouvoir faire de la télé consultation
médicale puisque mon objectif c'était de
trouver du temps médical parce qu'à
partir du moment où j'avais les médecins
donc c'était conditions posées par la
cnam a pas du moment où j'avais des
messins qui était sur mon territoire et
qu'ils pouvaient faire les
téléconsultations ceci débloquer le
problème du remboursement
de la caisse primaire d'assurance
maladie donc là actuellement on a donc
ça c'était à peu près de deux ans donc
le coc vide est passée par là c'est
important parce que l'après coville a
complètement changé la façon y compris
les médecins d'aborder la télémédecine
parce qu'il sait autant il était très
opposé avant autant aujourd'hui c'est un
peu plus ouvert sur la pratique est donc
là on va en voir revoir la discussion
mais comme c'est des rapports de
médecins m'ont la commune n'intervient
pas ça sera donc l'entreprise h cadets
qui va gérer donc un conventionnement
avec la cps pour que des médecins
s'il n'ya pas disponibilité au sein d'
assez pts pour fêter les consultations
puisse donc à l'extérieur du territoire
donc en dehors de la région centre est
où le du département de l'eure-et-loir
puissent prendre le relais pour faire
les téléconsultations voila voila un
petit peu le schéma vers quoi faire
quand on s'oriente
ce qui est important aussi j'ai pas
préciser tout à l'heure c'est que en
fait le principe c'est pas se dire je
mets une solution technique pour
apporter des soins c'est que je monte un
projet médical et ça a été le cas
puisque pourquoi un projet médical parce
que derrière vous avez de la
coordination médicale et donc moi je
voulais que les deux hôpitaux de
chartres et dreux soient informés
d'ailleurs j'ai reçu le directeur de
l'hôpital de dreux qu'est venu faire une
démonstration et quand une personne est
en difficulté il faut qu'on puisse
derrière organiser la coordination si
une personne est en difficulté on ait eu
qu'un aussi on en a on a sauvé le déni
des vies pour que le médecin une fois
qu'il a fait son analyse et son
diagnostic médical s'il détecte une
difficulté puissent contacter un médecin
urgentiste de l'hôpital et y coordonne
la prise en charge du patient puisque
dans un cas c'est le this donc les
pompiers qui sont venus chercher la
personne qui ont amené directement aux
urgences et dans d'autres cas c'est
celle des personnes soit allé tout seul
mais je viens il ya une coordination
cirque quand la personne arrive à
l'hôpital le diagnostic est déjà fait
donc c'est un gain phénoménale et ça
diminue
comme on le dit dans dans l'étude de 30%
les personnes qui se déplacent aux
urgences pour entre guillemets la
bobologie juste un chiffre que je vais
vous donner qui est issu lier la
première étude une consultation pour
entre guillemets la bobologie d'un
patient à au service des urgences à
sharp pour la calculer en moyenne ces
164 euros
quand on sait que si elle était mise en
laqué mise sur écoute et 24 euros 25
euros par an donc en termes de coûts
déjà en terme de distance et je ne mets
pas de rien le coût de transport etc etc
en d'autres termes les quatre médecins
urgentistes de l'eure et loir sont venus
aussi découvrir la cabine
ça permet aussi de faire de pas mal
d'économies sur le problème du transport
allégé aussi les services 12 disent
qu'ils sont souvent surchargés et
beaucoup pour du transport là derrière
les conséquences elles sont là dessus
alors après la question s'était prise en
charge médecins locaux
j'ai perdu le sens de la question j'ai
peut-être un peu répandu sur la par
rapport à la cpt est en fait la
difficulté quand on connaît la
difficulté qu'on a depuis le départ
c'est qu'on essaye d'expliquer que si on
n'a pas de temps médical et on n'a pas
suffi de suffisamment de médecins
comment fait-on pour pouvoir apporter
justement les téléconsultations et ça
c'est vraiment un débat et puis je
voudrais juste aussi apporté un élément
il faut bien faire la distinction et ça
peut-être c'est dans le cas de la
différenciation
ce qui est un acte de télémédecine je
pense qu'il faut faire la
différenciation de mon point de vue
entre un watt zappé ou un facebook ou
une consultation par un téléphone où
l'on en visio avec un médecin qui va ou
10 ans et c est la cabine de
téléconsultation là où le système avec
une infirmière ou là on est plutôt sur
un examen médical
on peut pas rembourser juste un appel
téléphonique de la même manière qu'on va
faire une consultation dans la cabine de
au favril la consultation dure
obligatoirement 20 minutes hier qu'il ya
un diagnostic complet donc dans la
différenciation il faut peut-être comme
on a ouvert on à faire entre guillemets
excusez moi du terme open bar sur les
téléconsultations médicales
il faut peut-être aussi voir si la la la
le remboursement il est le même que soit
jeu quand je fais du renouvellement par
téléphone ou quand je fais une
consultation de 20 minutes a dit sandy
essentielle ça c'est ça c'est un élément
assez important après la difficulté
c'est qui je pense qu'il est plutôt
favorable et on a travaillé au sein des
maires ruraux de france dans une
commission sur justement le sujet on
préfère privilégier la le territoire
parce que justement les médecins du
territoire connaissent bien
j'ai dans leur territoire en terme de
présence médicale pour gérer justement
cette coordination
pour autant il faut pouvoir libérer le
fait qu'un médecin dès lors qu'on n'a
pas suffisamment de médecins dans un
territoire puisse faire de la
téléconsultation quel que soit l'endroit
il soit sur le territoire national à
dire que le principe même de la
télémédecine
c'est le même principe que la télévision
conférence c'est qu'on peut faire des
choses à distance donc si quand on fait
quelque chose à distance on y met déjà
le premier frein c'est la distance elle
même sa puissance j'imagine pas faire
des visioconférences avec un collègue
dans un bureau d'un côté ça aucun sens
donc à un moment donné il faut aussi
peut-être amené une modernisation dans
le côté ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
privilégier satire il faut peut-être pas
faire open bar
comme dirait l'autre elle suit des
années là comme ça mais pour autant il
faut lire et ça aujourd'hui c'est une
vraie contrainte je sais pas si j'ai
répondu à toutes les questions
pour monsieur le maire monsieur le maire
concernant la ville grouille la dernière
remarque elle est tout à fait pertinente
et je reviendrai pas dessus parce que
j'aurais pas dit mieux
ah les newbies donc nous avons le coût
de la télémédecine donc nous avons
acheté le cabinet médical qui nous a
coûté 150 mille euros nous avons aussi
pris en charge la secrétaire qui
écoutent 25000 euros par an charger
l'appareil coup de 25000 euros mais il
nous est gracieusement prêtée par aupic
médical mais là c'est un échange de bons
procédés je voulais prouver que ça
marche moi j'avais besoin de sauver ma
population donc le deal c'est que tant
qu'on n'est pas remboursé ils me font le
prêt à titre gracieux et je l'achèterai
au moment venu et des consultations nous
coûte entre 80 et 100 mille euros par an
et les médecins sont payés au forfait
non pas la consultation dont qui est
qu'un patient ou 20 patients
c'est le même tarif et c'est ce qui m'a
permis de l'ouvrir d'ailleurs à des gens
qui habitent parfois 50 km mais à offrir
une solution médicale pour en revenir à
la notion de
de ces tps et de s p donc sur la
communauté de communes du yeun courtois
il ya un projet effectivement de maison
médicale qui est en cours mais je fasse
je suis désolé c'est une bêtise absolue
parce qu'on fait des maisons médicales
partout on n'a pas de médecin mettre
dedans donc c'est complètement con je
suis désolé de dire ça comme ça mais y'a
pas d'autres mondes et résultat on nous
demande de faire une maison médicale à
un million cinq cent mille euros presque
2 millions d'euros pour des médecins qui
sont déjà en place super ce que je vous
disais les médecins ce sont des libéraux
qui aime bien l'argent public je suis
désolé j'ai rien contre les médecins mes
meilleures amies son médecin mais des
fois c'est compliqué et donc aujourd'hui
la grèce est sorti du jeu et c'est la
cpm qui a repris la main et là j'ai très
bon contact avec la directrice de la
cpam de l'oise
et son adjointe le problème c'est que
bien évidemment il faut qu'on monte une
équipe de soins primaires avec le
médecin qu'on a à mi temps sur les
nouvelles parce qu'on a quand même
trouvé un médecin mi-temps les
infirmières et la pharmacie pour monter
une spl à rattacher à la cité ps qui est
existante uniquement sur le papier pour
ensuite pouvoir espérer un remboursement
sauf que sauf que ce extraordinaire une
fois encore encore un obstacle
j'ai appris la il ya quinze jours que
désormais où il faut qu'on passe par une
nouvelle commission de médecins locaux
soit disant consultative qui valise ou
non la télémédecine pour cette es
pirates achètent ctps donc c'est encore
un truc nouveau qui a été pendu enfin
c'est quand même formidable en france on
parle de séparation des pouvoirs on
parle de deux prises d'intérêts mais on
est quand même un des seuls pays où les
médecins font les règles pour eux mêmes
ils sont juges et parties font les
règles pour eux-mêmes faut quand même
pas oublier que ce sont quand même en
partie les médecins qui ont créé le
numerus clausus sous monsieur juppé et
qu'ils étaient à l'époque la première
représentation socioprofessionnelles à
l'assemblée nationale et qu'aujourd'hui
la pénurie a été sciemment organisé je
suis désolé c'est pas bien ce que je dis
mais je le dis quand même que c'est
profondément ce que je pense et donc
aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans cette
situation là parce que bien évidemment
les corporatismes et les lobbys ont
organisé quelque part cette pénurie
et là où on nage en pleine hypocrisie et
là j'en reviens à cette période du coc
vide c'est que je ne suis ni reconnus
par la rs ni remboursés mais lorsque les
gens appeler les médecins en pleine
période de qu'ovide et qu'ils donnaient
leurs symptômes le médecin dit hop hop
hop hop hop
moi je vous reçois pas c'est trop
dangereux par contre aller à la
télémédecine de laigneville il vous
recevront là-bas sans problème résultat
les infirmières elles ont fait depuis un
an et demi
toutes les consultations qu'ovide du
coin incroyable et comme on était pas
reconnue par la rs
on a eu droit à aucun matériel de
protection il a fallu que je fasse des
appels et d'ailleurs dans le livre et
que je vous ai donné et il en est fait
mention à la population pour que mes
infirmières puissent être protégés donc
ce sont des garagistes des pizzaïolos
des peintres qui ont offert des masques
des lunettes des tabliers et donc ça le
sait enfin c'était quand même c'est
surréaliste d'avoir pizza gaby au
cabinet de télémédecine mais c'était la
réalité et on avait même des infirmières
de laigneville qui travaillaient à
l'hôpital qui piquait du matériel pour
aller l'offrir au cabinet télémédecine
voilà où on en est arrivé et c'est là où
on voit quoi nage en pleine hypocrisie
par rapport à ça il était bien content
lorsqu'il y avait sept télémédecine ne
pas se mettre eux en danger alors que ça
le dérangeait pas du tout de mettre nos
infirmières en danger et ça c'est la
réalité
et lorsque à la fin de la crise du coc
vide j'ai demandé à la préfète que soit
remis une médaille pour acte de courage
dévouement des infirmières parce
qu'elles se sont véritablement mis en
danger
on m'a dit franchement si vous croyez
que se sont mises en danger
donc voila voila on est aujourd'hui
c'est compliqué donc du coup j'aurais
remis seulement la médaille de la ville
voilà certainement merci monsieur le
maire la parole est un autre collègue
jean-michel houlgate
merci madame la présidente bien
messieurs les maires je voudrais d'abord
peut-être vous féliciter pour votre
détermination votre persévérance à
vouloir comme sa traversée ces champs de
mines alors ma première question elle
rejoint peut-être déjà des éléments que
vous avez souligné mais on va avoir la
loi cadre des donc je ne sais pas s'ils
s'appellent ilkhan deux ou trois déesses
m'enfin bon peu importe mais toujours
est il qu'elle va être
elle pas de goûts de luxe elle va être
sur le bureau du sénat normalement donc
d'ici peu de temps et sera examiné en
plénière au mois de juillet est-ce que
vous avez identifié des freins
législatif qui pourrait d'une certaine
façon et bien nous nous faire l'objet
d'amendements ou autres pour bonifier
cette loi
cette loi cadre des jets une deuxième
question
vous êtes des offreurs de solutions
comment avez vous arrivez vous à gérer
entre le fait qu' il faut promouvoir
bien évidemment les initiatives et les
solutions techniques qui sont les vôtres
sans être automatiquement juin pour un
mot très fort inféodés à une solution
technologique donc à une entreprise qui
devient elle offre aux deux solutions et
puis ma dernière question pour monsieur
didier trichez vous fait vous avez fait
un centre municipal de santé en quelque
sorte de télémédecine est-ce que vous
avez des relations avec les centres
municipaux est ce que vous pouvez vous
faire agréer ou pas et quelles sont les
difficultés qui à l'heure actuelle se
font jour pour pouvoir avoir cette
labellisation centre municipal de santé
ici alors je compléterai peut-être les
questions de notre collègue jean-michel
j'ai entendu monsieur le maire de
l'offre le favori de ce que vous
expliquez très justement enseigne à un
moment la nécessité d'être un peu en
réseau parce que parfois la question que
vous avez vous pouvez pas traiter au pas
la traiter mais elle nécessite une autre
contribution
donc je pense qu'on voit bien vous êtes
partis comme les inventeurs ne possible
que sont les maires alors vous avez
inventé une solution qui marche qui est
satisfaisante et qu'à un moment il faut
qu'ils des ouvertures de la part de
partenaires qui dans un premier temps
sont frileux n'aime pas pour que
l'objectif que vous avez quel service à
vos habitants c'est pas le maire qui a
soudainement envie d'être médecin ce pas
votre sujet et comme vous dites les
théoriquement spa merde sur les services
mais vous c'est bien que les habitants
il ment amer d'être épicier de tenir la
poste de médecin et tout ça enfin on
connaît tous sa mort donc comment est ce
que on
arriva à ouvrir les choses deuxièmement
parfois vous savez on à chevaux
moi j'aime pas trop mais je vais le
prendre parce qu'il permet de comprendre
l'échelle de pertinence élire un moment
il ya une sorte de seuil d'efficacité
celeron voit bien que la question
elle arrive des habitants à la commune
et que la commune c'est cette échelle
d'efficacité de proximité ou comme le
dit le président larcher on a apporté
dans la région donc la question si on la
comprend pas le lundi ils vont nous
arrêter de mardi à mercredi au plus tard
jeudi faut avoir la solution est donc il
faut aller vite
est ce que il y a aussi des échelles de
coopération entre communes ou à deux ou
trois communes on agit parfois ça peut
être l'interco moi je suis pas du tout
favorable à la transmission ou au
transfert à l'inter coutume les
compétents mais parfois ça peut être à
une échelle voilà ensuite monsieur le
maire moi j'ai bien entendu monsieur
marc henrie ce que vous faites et la
manière dont on dirait d'une manière
simple vous assurer quoi hu a enfin vous
assurez au sens le truc il est la bouffe
est ça ma bon j'ai deux questions une
première une roma moi je suis assez
fasciné qu'une commune disent ça me
coûte cent mille euros j'assume
vous considérez
que l'accès aux soins est une priorité
pour vous libre administration moi s'en
va en même temps si je puis dire ça me
gêne qu'un maire soit obligé de versa à
cette hauteur parce que l'accès à la
santé
c'est un droit pour tous et qu'il existe
en france une un système plutôt à ses
rangs marc table de prise en charge de
la santé par la sécurité sociale et que
on constate que dans un endroit où il y
avait une difficulté particulière où le
main il a monté un truc en plus ils
payent bon voilà et moi je suis pas du
tout soviétique 1 mais bon franchement
ça me gêne un peu ça serait ça se
verrait
merci de me rassurer et dernier point la
commune elle prend en charge pour cent
mille euros mais vous l'aï dit tout à
l'heure vous avez des habitants d'autres
communes qui viennent
alors quand ça se passe est ce que c'est
vous qui payez pour toucher qui effrite
voilà je suis désolé j'ai mangé la
question de 2,2 philippaerts donne moi
ta fille voilà alors je vais vous
répondre
déjà à vos questions de stress à me dire
que moi je considère que c'est un
problème de santé publique
tout simplement et donc le problème
c'est qu'effectivement par contre on a
affaire à des intérêts à des
corporatismes qui n'ont rien à voir avec
des problématiques de santé publique et
moi par contre je restais sur mon
problème de santé publique donc j'ai
traité ça comme un problème de santé
publique et donc du coup et un moment où
j'ai dû prendre les choses en main et
effectivement j'ai eu des remarques de
la part des habitants me disant mais
attendez il faudrait ouvrir seulement
aux habitants laigneville j'ai dit mais
ça n'a aucun intérêt puisque de toute
manière qui est dit patient ou 20
patients c'est le même tarif
donc c'est pour ça que j'étais ouvert à
tout le monde et aujourd'hui on n'a que
quatre médecins sur la com de com et je
vous garantis que mes collègues maires
de la communauté de communes de lyon
courtois sont bien contents qu à
laigneville on prenne en compte leur
patience parce que sinon ils feraient
tous au siège de leur bureau
comme moi j'ai vécu lorsque mes médecins
sont partis mais pour autant ce n'est
pas pour ça qu'il m'accompagne ou qu'il
met donc ils me soutiennent ils font les
canards et ils regardent leurs
chaussures voilà un petit peu la réalité
de la situation
pardon car le canard c'est ne rien dire
oui la coin coin et on regarde on
regarde ses chaussures et on laisse le
maire de dugny villes se débrouiller on
est bien content qu'il le fasse on est
bien content de pas avoir eu à le faire
nous mais surtout surtout on évite de
mettre le doigt là dedans parce qu'on
veut pas se mettre à dos avec les
administrations et tout ça est donc j'en
reviens à la question qui était posée
par monsieur gâte sur les freins les
freins ne sont pas légaux au sens propre
du terme ils sont administratif oui ils
sont purement administratif notre pays
aujourd'hui n'est plus gouverné il est
administré et ça c'est un drame c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui les administrations
ont pris le pouvoir sur les élus moi
j'ai appris que la décision était
politique et qu ensuite l'administration
soutenait l'action politique aujourd'hui
on a des administrations qui font leur
propre interprétation des lois et qui
les imposent aux élus et le fond du
problème il est là je vais vous donner
un exemple très simple
alors vous avez vu la difficulté que
j'ai eue pour mettre en place la
télémédecine mais pendant la crise du
coc vide
ça a été un révélateur extraordinaire de
l'impotence et de l'omnipotence de nos
administrations elles ont été incapables
de répondre au moindre problème lié aux
qu'ovide qui a répondu aux problèmes de
locaux vides
si ce pays à traverser cette crise
sanitaire pas trop mal c'est parce qu'il
ya trente-six mille conseillers
municipaux en france qui se sont relevés
des manches et qui sans rien attendre ni
du gouvernement ni de qui que ce soit ni
encore moins des administrations ont
pris le problème à bras le corps moi
quand j'ai reçu le protocole sanitaire
des écoles mais il est allé à la
poubelle jeudi mais c'est pas possible
il rêve ces gens là ils se rendent même
pas compte de la réalité du terrain
j'étais la seule commune à ne pas
rouvrir les écoles de l'année
l'année dernière tout simplement parce
que j'ai mis en place une garderie
gratuite pour permettre aux gens d'aller
au travail et donc le sous préfet m'a
dit en douce vous aurez une classe l'air
de rien et je vous laisse lire ce que
vous voulez voilà où on en est
aujourd'hui et et on voit là vous
parliez tout à l'heure des communautés
de communes les communautés de communes
et les régions ont été totalement
absente mais totalement absente de la
crise du coup vide les seuls qui ont
répandu chez les communes et les
départements d'un point de vue
économique et la vraie difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est que a donné toutes ses
compétences aux communautés de communes
on voit les effets fallacieux de la loi
nôtre et qui vise à asphyxier
administrativement et financièrement les
communes qui lisent à leurs pertes à
leur disparition très rapide et le
problème c'est que arrêtons de regarder
ce que font les allemands ou les autres
on à 36000 communes en france mais c'est
36000 communes
qu'est ce qu'elles font aujourd'hui être
permettre de mettre la république à la
portée de tous et on n'a jamais eu
autant besoin qu aujourd'hui de pouvoir
mettre justement la république à la
portée de tous supprimer les communes
c'est une connerie je vous le dis et les
échelons les plus efficaces aujourd'hui
ce sont les communes les départements
je sais pas si vous avez dit lu le livre
de christophe guilluy la france
périphérique
c'est absolument passionnant parce que
je me retrouve totalement dans ce qu'il
décrit et je pense que beaucoup nous
administration devrait ce saint spire et
de ski a écrit christophe guilluy ou
sinon de venir faire un stage avec moi
pendant quelques jours là mais vraiment
aujourd'hui il est temps que
l'administration retourne à sa place et
que les élus reprennent leur place
décisionnaires travaux de vous laisser
la parole monsieur le fais je voudrais
en écho à ce que vous dites c'est pas
réagir mais notre collègue olga des
religions au projet de loi qui arrivent
là le
cette chose qui s'appelle cannes des
décentralisations sont des outils nous
notre objectif au sénat c'est le 1
d'efficacité c'est à dire un sénateur
c'est un peu comme un maire les outils
c'est fait pour servir un objectif et
nous c'est l'efficacité de l'action
publique jusqu'au dernier kilomètre bon
et que quand vous dites que la commune
c'est le socle mais vous parlez au coeur
des sénateurs moi je n'ai jamais entendu
au sénat un sénateur défendre l'idée que
la commune sur un truc extrêmement vous
n'avez pas dit du tout mais je veux
vraiment vous confortez non je sais bien
mais c'est l'idée voilà c'est juste pour
dire que nous nous pensons moi je suis
co rapporteur du texte à canet et peut
nous c'est simple on a deux mots
l'objectif c'est efficacité de l'action
publique soudain et qu'ils ont et
comment on construit ça à partir d'un
seulement c'est le principe de
subsidiarité
c'est à dire la médecine faut que sois
proche chamassian dupont est pas là je
fais peut-être que dans tel endroit il
ya quatre ou cinq communes qui veulent
le faire faisons le ensemble
donc c'est laisser aux territoires
s'organiser librement et surtout dire
que tout doit partir de la commune et
après on dispatche parce que on a une
exigence d'efficacité mais vous l'avez
dit les gilets jaunes ont montré et la
coville a montré une exigence de
proximité voilà donc vraiment nous on va
on va avoir des sujets les chips que
dans la loi dans le projet de loi cadets
il est question de permettre notamment à
des départs tandis interco d'ouvrir des
centres de santé alors pourquoi pas sauf
que nous la question qu'on pose kybele
d'accord parce que ça veut dire quand
même un bon moi je trouve ça crame ya un
conte ou permettent qu'on légalise et
qu'on fasse qu'on reconnaisse qu'il y
aura accès à sécurité sociale comme dans
tout le monde
ok sauf que il ne faut pas qu'on demande
aux communes de se substituer à ce qui
doit être le rôle de l'état un moment
d'état doit garantir l'accès a senti que
vous fassiez ça c'est parfait
merveilleux et c'est pas vous qui devez
payer
voilà et puis après je laisserais
monsieur le maire pardon
excusez moi le problème ce n'est pas
tant la leurs cadets c'est
l'interprétation qui voit renaître fait
ensuite par les administrations c'est
bien vous avez dit et alors ce sera mon
dernier mot vous avez raison c'est moi
je pense qu'aujourd'hui les politiques
ils doivent imprimer leurs ma c'est vous
vous dites et je vous entends du tout
vous dire nous on a un sujet et si c'est
pas le maire qui pense à bras le corps
il manque à son devoir
d'accord donc c'est vous qui le porte et
l'administration doit vous aider à
trouver des solutions au lieu de vous
même des bâtons et je trouve que y
compris au sénat quand on nous dit nous
on dit voilà on peut différencier serre
dans un territoire
peut-être que l'intergroupe fait un truc
mais juste pour deux communes ça non
mais alors là vous comprenez ça va pas
être possible parce que quand on demande
pourquoi c'est pas possible
alors peut-être qu'on a un problème de
quille qu'on comprend pas très bien on a
du mal à être convaincus et que je pense
qu'il faut effectivement que commerçant
exemplaire dans tout ça c'est à dire
vous vous faites vous trouver des sujets
que quand on innove par nature il n'y a
pas de point de comparaison par contre
l'innovation que vous faites qui hors
norme elle va servir à te dire de quoi
voyez vous voyez bien donner plutôt
totalement vote à vos côtés comme le
disait philippe mouillé nous on
s'inspire de ce qui est fait dans les
territoires de toutes les initiatives
pour communiquer parfois pour reprendre
des choses dans la loi pour améliorer
mais c'est le maire de fébriles
pardonnez moi je vous en prie et si elle
vient à point ou que je partage avec
vous c'est que comment se fait-il qu'on
en soit arrivé que ce soit les communes
qui prennent en charge quelque chose qui
est normalement porter par par le
national alors après peut-être la faute
aussi nous peut on peut peut-être aussi
balayer devant notre porte
si on le faisait pas il faut bien
quelqu'un qui le fasse mais c'est vrai
que quand on est maire on a cette
relation avec la population et et on a
envie d'apporter et quand vous êtes
harcelé à longueur de journée pour venir
monsieur le maire essayer de faire
quelque chose pour tel sujet donc on
prend part au sujet bon après pour par
rapport à la loire je pense honnêtement
pour être franc avec vous je vois pas ce
que la loi cadre des basques dans la loi
qu'a dit ce qu'elle peut apporter
puisqu'on n'est plus sur un sujet qui
relève de la sécurité sociale sur les
conditions de remboursement
après on peut l'organiser alors j'ai vu
effectivement je crois je me suis un
pull nul de l'article sur le fait que
les régions et les départements vont
pouvoir investir
la question qu'il faut se poser aussi
par rapport à qui paye tout à l'heure
comme le boul dizier est ce que l'on
risque pas d'avoir un territoire qui
soit plus riche qu'un autre qui soit
forcément ou moins bien dotées canaux
donc attention à cette répartition
donc on est bien sûr une logique
d'aménagement du territoire en fait on
est sur une logique d'aménagement du
territoire et la logique de
l'aménagement du territoire c'est bien
l'équilibré
les maires ruraux de france bat
suffisamment pour expliquer un équilibre
entre la ville et la campagne
donc est là l'accès aux soins
je rappelle quand même dans les cahiers
de doléances suite à la crise des gilet
jaune
la première revendication n'est de nos
cahiers de doléances qu'on avait lancé
c'est l'accès aux soins quand même donc
ça veut dire que c'est un sujet
fondamental et on est plus encore une
fois dans la réaction plutôt que dans
l'anticipation puisqu'on a un souci en
france mais là ça dépasse la de la
commission on n'est pas là on peut pas
faire de la prévention
voilà donc donc aujourd'hui
l'idée c'est pas de remplacer l'un par
l'autre parce que le fait est là je
pense qu'il faut qu'à une logique de
d'aménagement territorial un responsble
est elle celle de la région à l'échelle
du département
personnellement je préfère le
département c'est plus en proximité mais
qui est un travail commun d'aménagement
de la présence médicale parce qu'il n'ya
pas que la télémédecine c'est la
présence aussi de médecins c'est aussi
la présence d'hôpitaux de proximité
donc voilà il ya une espèce
d'organisation qui fait ça est ce que on
donne tout à la rs tous les pouvoirs
l'art est donc notamment nous on demande
à ce qu'il y ait des membres élus au
sein des ars à tous et peut être ces
sujets là qu'il faut que c'est peut-être
plus de présence des élus dans dans les
organisations pour qui les meilleurs
jeux venir intégration de la visibilité
territoriale puisque parfois on pourrait
imaginer même à l'échelle d'une région
vous voir à l'échelle d'un département
une espèce de 2 comment dire quand on
dit lui s'est vu d'en haut mais s'est
pas vu sur le terrain et donc il faut
travailler ça donc moi je verrais plus
par rapport à ça après si vous avez
abordé l'intercommunalité
tout le monde connaît bien la définition
même est essentiel de l'intercommunalité
qui n'est pas une collectivité je le
rappelle qui est de faire à plusieurs ce
que l'on peut pas faire tout seul donc
pourquoi pas enfin gère aujourd'hui les
maisons de santé sont portés en majorité
par les par les intercommunalités en
essayant de faire justement un équilibre
effectivement on a une difficulté à
trouver des médecins pour y mettre
pour m maintenant est-ce qu'ils ont peut
pas se mettre autour de la table au sein
d'un département avec la rs et moi
j'insiste sur cette notion départemental
par rapport à la proximité du territoire
parce que chaque même dans une région
les départements seront parfois
différents et pour essayer de repenser
la présence médicale en termes
d'organisation mais ça veut dire aussi
qui va faire que les médecins et je
passe un message
j'ai déjà dit à plusieurs reprises pour
avoir rencontré beaucoup de médecins
s'ils ne s'empare pas du sujet s'ils ne
ne s'empare pas le sujet s'y opposent
ils vont se prendre de plein fouet le
contrecoup parce que quand je vous
observe que la nature a horreur du vide
et je mets souvent
expérience des chauffeurs de taxi compas
vu hubert arriver donc il faut anticiper
mettons nous tournons là train à table
je pense que les faits légers insiste
cette notion avant et après qu vide
je pense que maintenant les médecins ou
bien compris quel était l'intérêt de la
télémédecine
parce que là on parle de la médecine
générale mais aussi on pourrait parler
de la médecine des expertises la
dermatologie ont dit que la psy qu'elle
à la psychiatrie par le 5 avril à la
psychologie c'est aussi des sujets qui
marche très bien enfin il ya des sujets
aujourd'hui en télémédecine qui
fonctionne très bien et faisons de
l'aménagement nos concitoyens dans nos
campagnes ne doivent pas excusez moi
d'insister sur cette notion rural mais
nous pas on ne doivent pas être écartée
on a sorti un certain d'études
dernièrement au sein des maires ruraux
de france pour faire la démonstration
qu'on vit moins longtemps la campagne
parce qu'on a moins accès aux soins
c'est factuel c'est les chiffres donc
c'est ça qu'il faut faire nous repensons
l'organisation avec les messins avec
l'organisation des hôpitaux et en y
intégrant des solutions de télémédecine
mais pas n'importe quelle solution de
télémédecine j'insiste là dessus parce
que c'est vrai que là les opportunités
se sont aussi ouvertes beaucoup
d'opérateurs divers et variés ont font
des propositions et nous on n'est pas
des spécialistes et faut pas non plus
qu'on nous vend n'importe quoi
[Musique]